-I don't know if you guy
saw this,
but I just read
Dollar Tree is planning to open
600 new stores this year.
-What?!
-That's a pretty big expansion.
I think it deserves
a little appreciation.
In fact, right now,
I'd like to sing an ode
to dollar stores.
Roots.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
♪ Dollar store ♪
♪ Oh, dollar store ♪
♪ Weirder stuff ♪
♪ Than I bargained for ♪
♪ Like calendars ♪
♪ That are one year off ♪
♪ And generic candy ♪
♪ That makes me cough ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Coughs ]
♪ Dollar store ♪
♪ Sweet dollar store ♪
♪ Greeting cards ♪
♪ With typos galore ♪
♪ I love to search ♪
♪ Your crowded halls ♪
♪ For a bin of off-brand ♪
♪ Barbie dolls ♪
♪ Dollar store ♪
♪ My dollar store ♪
♪ Even though the quality ♪
♪ May be poor ♪
♪ There's a cheapness that ♪
♪ I can't ignore ♪
♪ And you know that I'll be ♪
♪ Back for more ♪
♪ Oh, dollar ♪
♪ Store ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Stick around!
We'll be right back
with Tracy Morgan
and "Tonight Show Hashtags"!
♪♪